[Music]
forty-three seconds of logos deep in the
undergrowth I spot something extra for a
movie steals the exact same newsreel
footage opening from pop if you look
closely you can see young Carl hoping
you'll be Charles Muntz in this scene
this incredible old-timey newsreel
documentary crew not only managed not to
freak out and drop the camera when the
bear appear but got to different angles
to cut together perfectly this is London
that's where I'm from and these bears
picked up English fast Caesar needed a
special serum and three movies to get it
down but these Bears have it in the
first three minutes also I get that they
learned some English from Montgomery but
how did they continue to learn English
once he left and I know we're about to
see them listening to records but I
still ask the question how did they
learn to understand the words they had
not already learned Weinstein so the
Bears kept the names Montgomery gave
them I mean they had bare names right
[Music]
right okay I'm not gonna lie this
Paddington curb is about the most
adorable thing I've ever seen I'll take
a few students off right now just to
ease my conscience for tearing this
sweetness a new Earth's whole for the
next ten minutes setting aside the
opposable thumb issue for these bears to
construct this contraption through the
woods would not only have taken more
years than their lifespan would allow
but all sorts of construction equipment
they just don't have we've been talking
about that trip for 40 years I'm sad to
report that the Peruvian spectacled
bears lifespan is just over 20 years
meaning these two are obviously ghost
bears and some horrible horrible is
about to go down
no buts it's about time I got a bit of
respect around here
demanding respect but then something
embarrassing it happens to you at that
moment cliche can we talk about
electricity how are they getting it for
this record player at least have the
decency to Flintstone in some jungle
hamsters or something
setting aside Paul bears ability to
throw ma bear over his shoulder this
easy why doesn't she have a direct chair
route to the shelter like we saw earlier
maybe you should invest a bit more
infrastructure into safety instead of
marmalade production if Distaso is this
strong why on earth did he ever put aunt
Lucy back down in the first place
jungle bear is smart enough to learn the
English language meant build an entire
marmalade Factory in the jungle but
somehow doesn't know to run when danger
is approaching Lucy do they teach the
death of a parent or guardian rule in
the how to write a family film classes
can nobody think of a better way to
provide character development or
motivation on a Paddington's most
charming accessories is acquired and
morbid way possible stay out of sight
until London I don't know this boat is
going to London
aren't you coming I am too old too tired
to go any further
Oh movie makes up some nonsense about a
home for retired bears but you are
abandoning a child who needs you after
losing his father figure the honest
answer isn't that you're too old it's
that the script needs you out of the
picture I would be safe in the home for
retired bears it was once a war in the
exporters country thousands of children
were sent away for safety left at
railway stations with the labels around
their necks how does she know all this
also does she really think a bear is
going to be treated just like a human
child I mean she's just abandoning her
nephew and feeding him this crap so she
can go retire
Aunt Lucy kind of sucks it was basically
the same way I pack for a trip except
it's peanut M&Ms and Oreo thins when he
opened his case he had 15 jars of
marmalade so what's with the miraculous
multiplying marmalade mason jars this is
possibly the cleverest fart joke I've
ever seen but it's still a fart
joke somewhere in London a young child
will never read the final message sent
from his dying father in darkest Peru
because of The Selfish male jumping
marmalade chugging bear jerk good thing
Paddington happened to fall into the
mailbag that was going directly to the
train station because hey movies got a
movie even though he's smaller than your
average bear Paddington is still a bear
and no one notices him standing there on
the platform mysterious missing mail bag
cool shot bro but exactly why are none
of these people either embarking or
disembarking from these strengths go on
then
not gonna lie this movie is way funnier
than it has any right to be and it's
fine until you jumped in the lake
Victorian bathing pond darling and what
you're supposed to do not naked the
shape of water now in the Paddington an
expanded universe did you know bears
like marmalade I didn't even know bears
could talk then why the hell aren't you
freaking out right now although since
three years from now Mary will be having
sex with a sea creature
I guess housing a bear for a night might
seem normal the bed's even have names
mmm coffee though my name is it's a cute
joke and all but seriously mine doesn't
even have a human name already
posters oh and Lucy did why wouldn't
they give him one too he was just in a
train station all day and a restaurant
both of which had floors so I'm not sure
why he's acting so hesitant with this
floor
my knees never lie ladybirds knees
Shakira's hips the honest body parts
genre continues to grow I swear to God
movie if his tongue actually touches
that earwax I'm adding 10 cents don't do
it I swear to god don't you damn it the
water pressure is neither high enough or
pointed in the right direction to keep
this showerhead aloft setting aside that
an OP probably wouldn't end the water
flow how is this tub so dry I can't find
anything about an English explorer in
Peru well of course you can't I know
it's because that's not how the internet
works the table had legs now it does not
when Jonathan grows up he wants to be an
astronaut lost gee he built a pair of
rocket boots Paddington has been at this
house for what a couple hours at most
and the majority of that time was spent
destroying the bathroom so how does he
know so much about this family already
Madame director thirty minutes into the
movie and you just now decide to get
minh also obvious villain introduction
is obvious somehow the pigeons tracking
down Paddington for more marmalade is
the most believable thing to happen in
this movie so far don't believe I've had
the pleasure with Capaldi showing up in
the earlier Matt Lucas sighting I'm
beginning to think this just might be an
episode of Doctor Who which means
Paddington and his family are more
likely a group of talking bear aliens
who the doctor will eventually give a
speech to as he compassionately kicks
them off this planet just as well by any
of them music that's barest now watch
out there are thieves murderers and
pickpockets on every platform
considering Paddington made it through
an entire day at the train station by
himself I think he's got this some kind
of tiny police bear movie is already
conjuring up subtitles for future
sequels
calling cookies biscuits the sin is on
you England all of you at least you
didn't go with digestives Mary Poppins
the officers can see the cop hat as
Paddington whizzes by but can't tell
that's not a human underneath it I'm not
as concerned that he's holding that many
wallets as I am that they could all
spill out that easily what was the old
enough your father loves you very much
give him a chance he might just surprise
you mrs. bird has had 13 plus years of
hearing the kids complain about how off
other dad is so why would she hold onto
the story until now is it an English
custom to glue your hat to your head or
does gravity just work different across
the Pops I'm terribly
someone's looking for a new companion
also this scene must have been a
favorite of all the young Lionel Ritchie
fans in 2014 mr. Brown yeah did
Paddington already ride this elevator
sorry this lifts to another floor and
back why is it just opening now okay
fine
some forgetful custodial worker left
their whole cart in the lift but did
they also leave their clothes and makeup
and sense of humor he's never going to
work
missus Downton Fire would be excellent
at cinema since nothing draws a crowd
like a sandwich clogging the pneumatic
mail system that no one could have known
was gonna happen oh but it always starts
with just one Mr curry drains clogged
with fur
raucous night picnics Eyes Wide Shut to
the furry Chronicles Paddington knows
what tape is and its purpose but doesn't
understand how to tear it off the spool
Paddington is home alone wouldn't it
make more sense for a Millicent to use
the front door
she'd just ring the doorbell and say
marmalade Graham or some deus ex Rube
Goldberg it but it had the head of an
elephant and the body of a snake okay
fine the gas mask maybe sort of looks
like an elephant if you squint and have
a PhD and just believe suspension but
the body of a snake a snake and he's a
boy it's not much to go on the reality
of this movie is so confusing at the
time it's about a bear that no one seems
to think twice about walking around
talking and getting into mishaps but
then the other half is the exact
opposite you see my father is dead and I
suppose I hoped you might give me a home
even the kids are going to know this is
Millicent so the movies choice to hide
this twist once we hear her voice is
asinine I thought you were sending him
to Peru but I said I was sending him
where he belongs
Richard his case is the Natural History
Museum Millicent conveniently says where
she's taking Paddington in this contrive
meet up with curry
so the Browns can find out where to
rescue him from Montgomery Clyde I
hereby revoke your membership of this
hallowed guild isn't this just a
glorified Club how would they even
legally get a specimen back into the
country we could have been rich and
famous as a geographer but how are we
gonna get in it'll be locked up like a
fortress service what service didn't you
say they could take you anywhere in the
city you know that random conversation
we had out of nowhere and for no reason
20 minutes into the movie
50,000 volt we know I'm doing well if
you say so I get that it would take her
a minute to get ready for the stuffing
part but why wouldn't she already have
killed Paddington there's no need for
him to still be alive this movie is
about to do a 1 to direct nostalgia
punch of Indiana Jones and Mission
Impossible sure I liked it but I can
still smell the pandering all over you
it only took one shot from across the
room earlier but now a medicine can hit
Paddington from a closer distance with
multiple shots why is he speaking bear
here wouldn't he want the best chance
for them to hear and understand him it's
as if the movie wanted to force a way
for each family member to use something
unique to them to overcome this finale
we won't do that this is brown he's
family family you're not even the same
species this is a common thread and
sally hawkins filmography I swear that's
my last shape of water reference
Paddington is really just an origin
story for Millicent future serial killer
sandwich clearly dropped before it got
to Millicent so why are the pigeons
still going after her the door that big
is a horrible design flaw for insulation
and general practical use unless of
course you need a convenient last-second
save for your cute bear movie movie sets
up the band as the villains and the
sequel their rage stems from never being
tipped by the Browns even though they
passed them every day
and a bear in sight the bear patrol
might be working like a charm London is
not how we imagined it hardly anyone
says hello or wears hats because he
endangered
you must be Mr Gruber hands Bobby my
wife used to fart when she was nervous
your hack husband betrayed you on
October the 4th yeah maybe it's better
to spike it yeah okay could he buy my
mom one of the girls so she used to
dress me girlie clothing just became a
habit